we'll say this I'm a little surprised
I've I've been doing this for a really
long time and talked to a lot of people
I think you might be the first guest
that's come on just wearing a
windbreaker you like it yeah I like your
windbreaker yes thank you
well there's a story behind it a bit I'm
kind of promoting this now this company
a little bit because I got into a bit of
a problem with the last windbreaker I
had okay so I for my whole life for the
past ten years I wore this windbreaker
by a company in Vancouver named taiga it
would called taiga as anyway no and
they're they're only in Vancouver that
really make really good jackets you know
so I liked them and you wore the same I
wore it in my show I work it's in almost
every episode the first to see right in
between the seasons I found out this is
true that I found it they had published
a tribute to a notorious Holocaust
denier in their winter catalog seriously
yeah and it's I think I gave you a photo
of it we have it right next to this is a
tribute to a Holocaust denier and they
published it right next to their winter
socks and balaclavas there so a guy a
guy they're saying he's one of a kind
[Music]
you know we really need to be more like
him in these pieces time that's horrible
yeah and this guy like he he did a movie
review where he referred to Steven
Spielberg's oscar-winning 1994 film as
swindlers list you're kidding so that
was the end so you thought I'm not gonna
wear it's a catchy name for a review but
it's not you know the top subject
matters granted yeah it does well I was
in it I was in a problem because I'm
like as a Jew I'm like oh crap and you
know
you've been wearing this Jack yes and
you know in searching for a replacement
I realized I couldn't be sure that any
of these other jacket companies weren't
hiding dark secrets as well so I thought
the only way to be safe was to start a
jacket company of my own so this is my
yeah I came up with this yeah cool name
like summit ice is cool yeah so it's a
cool name you know and you know you know
undo the damage I'd done you know I
wanted it to stand for something as well
so summit ice you know I've launched is
the first outdoor apparel company to
openly promote the true story of the
Holocaust oh you know we're all about
quality you know we're all about you
know the jackets water-resistant it's
got a two-way stretch very breathable
and you know that six million Jews did
die you know we're all about the quality
and getting those facts out believing
the facts so you mention that in the
advertising yeah we're trying to you
know we're trying to promote the jacket
you know it's a cool jacket it's a
good-quality jacket but six million Jews
did die in that number is important and
we do want it we do want to make people
aware of that question are you I mean
that's a great that you're keeping that
message out there but how sure are you
that the company that's making the
jackets is aboveboard in other regards
do you not I mean
well you what do you mean like how do
you know that the company is like you
know treating its workers fairly and
paying them a fair wage like where the
jackets being made all that kind of
stuff you coating you have to pick your
cause honestly I don't know exactly I
mean when I when I called the it sounded
like a man on the phone you know not a
child but you know
I mean between the Holocaust awareness
and that I picked to the Holocaust but
actually children might be making these
jackets
you know honestly Conan when I came on
here I wasn't really expecting a you
know - this would be a witch-hunt you
know Barbara Walters style sorry you you
know Harry I'm sorry electing to talk to
more of you know a clown I'm gonna say
this again Nathan for you it airs
Thursdays at 10:00 on Comedy Central
funniest thing I've seen in memory
really hilarious show and you can see
Nathan at Comedy Central live on Friday
November 13th at King's Theatre in
Brooklyn Nathan fielder wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]